look listen
I hate to say this but flying cars will
never be a thing now I know I know
they're so epic they are 420 Thanos
Keanu Reeves Marvel epic science
machines and they might even turn you
into a pickle
however in real life flying cars would
either be a completely impractical B
hazardous C detrimental to your mental
health the entire concept is just
non-viable and when I say non-viable I
don't mean we will not see any flying
course period I do think they'll have
some kind of Niche application but
nothing beyond that flying cars by and
large are just a stupid concept and if
they were just that I wouldn't really
bother you know there's plenty of stupid
ideas out there and they usually die on
their own however I also think that
flying cores present a unique and exotic
danger and multiple dangers in fact and
that's the reason why this video exists
so how and why are flying cars such a
bad idea that's what we're going to look
at after a word from today's sponsor
Atlas VPN Atlas VPN offers a service
that encrypts your data behind your
virtual location from Brian guys it
helps you protect your privacy and
allows you to bypass those ever annoying
region locks with Atlas VPN you'll be
able to unlock all that content locked
away from you arbitrarily only based on
your location like on Netflix and other
streaming platforms all you need to do
is open the app pick a server and that's
it Atlas VPN also includes a breach
scanner function able to tell you if
there are any data leaks associated with
a given email address Atlas VPN also
allows you to block unwanted trackers
from websites with their new tracker
blocker feature all you need to do is
flip the switch right now Atlas VPN is
running a Black Friday sale where you
can get their service for just 1.70
cents per month plus six months extra
and of course a 30-day money-back
guarantee the link is in the description
atlas of course runs both on desktop and
mobile and is compatible across all
well-known operating systems protect
your privacy and don't let region blocks
stop you steal this Black Friday deal
today by clicking the link in the
description thank you for checking out
Atlas VPN ads like this helps support
what I do and now back to the video
so how and why are flying cars such a
horrendously bad idea let's look at the
first point practicality so the reason
why we came up with this thing called
transportation is to get to places
quicker so we can divide traveling into
three relevant categories short range
between 0 and 50 kilometers mid-range
between 50 and 500 kilometers and long
range which is about 500 kilometers
alright so I believe that here we can
already see the first problem namely
that flying cars just don't make a lot
of sense for short or long ranges if
your destination is within a short range
you can just walk cycle take public
transit or you know you can just drive
if those aren't an option and if you're
going long range well then you can just
take a train or an airplane or just
drive even because flying cars just
aren't that fast their top speeds are
generally 162 200 kilometers per hour
which is a bit more than highway speed
essentially and is very much inferior to
high speed rail and vastly inferior to
airplanes so the Practical use of flying
cars is basically limited to mid-range
only also you have to make sure that you
can land and or near the destination
also also you can't really use a flying
car if the weather is too bad you know
if there is a giant terrain storm or
snowstorm or the winds are too high also
also also if you're going at night you
have to make absolutely sure that your
destination has an illuminated landing
area and the thing about flying cars is
that they are essentially just foldable
Sports planes as such their structure is
very light and so very vulnerable so if
you go to a store in say land mode and
someone backs into you in the parking
lot and say dance one of your flaps then
you can't really fly until it gets
replaced so every time you use your
flying car in land mode you are one
slight bump away from weeks of no flying
and hundreds perhaps thousands of
dollars of service fees alright so
things aren't looking great for the
flying car so far you can only really
use it at a certain range in good
weather during daylight the destination
has to have Landing infrastructure and
even with the slightest damage you
immediately have to go to the repair
shop alright so let's move on to the
second aspect of flying cars namely the
hazard they pose so flying cars are
essentially have it on projectiles
flying around at moderate speeds and in
the case of mass adoption there would
also be a greater number of accidents
you know Billy Bob discovers a dent on
the right flap in the Walmart parking
lot and things to himself yeah it is
probably fine and then it turns out
mid-flight that it's not really fine
because of issues like this flying cars
would basically need to be banned above
all human settlements and basically all
other strategically important
infrastructure for example military
installations airports seaports high
voltage cables and then there's also the
environmental considerations meaning
that flying cars would need to be bent
above nature reserves migratory bird
roots and any other areas where they
might end up damaging or disturbing the
local Wildlife so in order to really
mitigate the hazard posed by flying cars
you would need to organize things
consider this map of Budapest and its
surrounding areas so where would our
no-fly zones be turns out pretty much
everywhere so the only real solution
here is to essentially establish
corridors you know places where you can
concentrate flying cars and focus on
minimizing their negative consequences
and you know order to avoid Chaos on the
roads like flying cars randomly taking
off and Landing you would need to
establish a whole bunch of huge air
strips where potentially hundreds of
flying cars can take off or land at the
same time and all this would need to be
coordinated of course somehow so once
again we are talking about the mass
adoption scenario and wow what a great
idea having these focused Busy Transit
corridors with some major Transit hubs
along the way where people can get on
and off if only Hungary had something
like this it would be such a great help
you know something which can move a lot
of people economically which is
absolutely perfect for Middle distances
something which runs along these
corridors and ends in these big Transit
hubs so to speak and someone should
really call Elon Musk about this because
this [ __ ] needs the inventing right now
I mean this would revolutionize our
Transit yeah um so anyway the third and
last aspect of flying cars that I want
to touch on is your mental health you
know even if flying cars would be flying
around settlements they would still make
a lot of noise and this would be true
even if a flying car would be only as
loud as a regular car flying course
travel at an altitude of around 2-3
kilometers generally for comparison
airliners travel at around 10 kilometers
now our current land-based highways are
already super loud but we can sound
proof them with air corridors this is
obviously not possible so he would be
looking at a constant background buzzing
even outside cities where I should say
especially outside cities you know the
places which should be actually quieter
and this of course would have a
devastating effect on everybody's mental
health no matter what you do no matter
where you go the meddling buzzing will
always be in your ear and I don't know
about you but for me personally this
would be a version of hell and the thing
is the more people adopt flying cars the
more severe these problems get but then
again I don't think they'll be adopted
in Mass because of the aforementioned
problems they're just too severe and all
this renders the concept of flying cars
effectively useless it's just another
form of inefficient individual transport
which we should be phasing out at this
point alright so this was my take on
flying cars and I haven't even mentioned
things like terrorism you know stuff
like building your flying car with
fertilizer or something and then can be
causing into a building
or you know load up a bunch of molotovs
and use it as a bomber even without
these the case against flying cars is
strong enough I think so anyway thank
you for watching don't forget to like
And subscribe and do check out my
patreon if you think this content is
worth your money and I'll be seeing you
next time